but your own mother I know she likes
visit you on sets did you visit you on
this set yes she did yeah because well
there's mom a lot of families like to
visit sets because they get to take
pictures with people and it's fun but
your mom's like hustling when she gets
to this absolutely yeah my mother yes
she says she wants to come to see me but
we already had that discussion mama if I
was an accountant in Chicago you
wouldn't want to come to me no I
wouldn't because what do I want to do
son I want to get in that movie she's
come into all my sets and she's she's
persistent and she has it she has a
pitch that she's not got not gotten
tired of she continues she's 86 now then
she she finds she comes to me and said
who's who's who's the personal and said
that can make it happen and I like that
guy and I've learned to send her to the
wrong people even then her pitch is this
okay remake of the Graduate what's so
funny what somebody notes great idea
like I'm the aunt Bancroft character
Matthew is the Dustin Hoffman and what
does everyone right away say wait a
minute that's pretty bent she's amazed
like Oh knock it off I've seen it before
it's not that big of a deal she's she
wants to do remake the Graduate she
started off one to just do Golden Girls
now she wants to do remake the Graduate
if she wants me to be the Dustin Hoffman
barn yeah there's someone make in this
you know what I know can I work I don't
know
[Music]